thanks adam
and your live chat thank you adam
well welcome everyone to this meeting of
the cabinet held on monday the 12th of
april
and before we formally start the meeting
i would like us to hold
two-minute silence uh in remembrance
of his royal highness prince philip duke
of edinburgh
in recognition of his long and
distinguished
distinguished service to the nation so
two minutes starting now please anne
in the next challenge thank you anne
um so without further ado on with the
meeting
and apologies for absence and
and we don't have any um apologies chen
would you like us to
do a role call i think that will be
appropriate anne
thank you for reminding me tactfully
thank you so yourself leader
you can hear all proceedings i can see
and hear the proceedings on
thank you councillor pemberton i can see
and hear the proceedings thank you anne
thank you councillor barker
i can see and hear the proceedings thank
you thank you councillor cargill
i can see and hear the proceedings thank
you thank you cancer harvey
should we come back to you welcome back
to council harvey councillor jennings
councillor jennings i can hear and see
your proceedings thank you councillor
kettle
uh councillor kettle i can see in here
proceedings
pew councillor parry
uh i can see proceedings i'm getting
i'm hearing people twice if not three
times
okay is that cancer harvey it is
okay i'm not sure why that is
if you cancel harry councillor parry
here
i can see and hear all the proceedings
thank you
thank you councillor shenton good
afternoon councillor shenton here i can
see
and hear the proceedings thank you very
much thank you we've also got cancers
junaid dixon and o'donnell with us today
thank you
thank you anne uh any disclosures of
interest
i'll take that as a no yes mr chairman
sorry her counselor kettle um
although the uh item five is the bishop
situation neighborhood development plan
although this has not been prepared by
the parish council
but by the neighborhood development plan
committee as a member of the parish
council
uh i think it's appropriate just to um
um declare that i am part of that parish
thank you councillor kettle uh
no more disclosures of interest in that
case
minutes uh is everyone happy with the
minutes of the meeting held on the 8th
of march
i'll take that as a yes so moving on to
matters to be referred to the council uh
cost strategy review assessment council
of pemberton
good afternoon chair and members of
committee
and you will all be aware that it is a
requirement
of the core strategy
process that each five years planning
authorities are required
to undergo and undertake an assessment
to decide whether their local plan
policies require updating
um the purpose of the report before you
on page five and onwards
is to for cabinet to formally endorse
the findings of the
review assessment which is set out in
appendices one of two
that the core strategy remains up to
date and continues to provide an
appropriate basis on which to plan
for stratfor upon haven district
council's
development plan to the year 2031.
officers have been through a thorough
exercise
uh assessed the key areas and i will
draw
members of cabinet's attention to
item 3.1 on page 7 which confirms
there is no evidence of any significant
change in local housing need
housing need numbers and therefore the
requirement objectively assessed is in
excess of the minimum local housing need
established by the 2020
standard methodology our housing
delivery test results are extremely
positive with the last published figure
showing us at 269 percent of required
delivery
the core strategy is delivering uh
affordable housing needs
yet again we've had a record year of
delivery on affordable housing
and any shortfalls that may arise from
any other areas around our duty to
cooperate are being managed through the
site allocations process
and as far as the climate emergency is
concerned the work done by officers
around
the preparation of a supplementary
planning
document um addresses
at least in the interim the requirements
of climate change as we all know
the the move towards fully addressing
climate change will be given life
through the new south wales
plan and therefore members i commend the
recommendation on page five
um to you it's a recommendation that
goes to council ultimately
uh but for the cabinet to endorse the
findings of the assessment
uh i do believe i have john carefort uh
albeit
that he is actually on leave this week
um so he and i have got to have a
conversation about work-life balance but
he is here to answer any questions from
cabinet
should they should they arise thank you
thank you councillor pemberton
i noticed councillor june wants to ask
you a couple of questions
before councillor junit asks the
questions
on page 10 uh 7.1
uh carry out a review of policies at
least every five years
is a legal requirement for all local
plans
uh does that include neighborhood
development plans please
uh thank you chair uh no the the
reasoning there is an implication
uh with the that neighborhood
development plans should be
reviewed the legislation however refers
only to
uh plans of local planning authorities
but
but by definition if you know if we were
in
embarking on a wholesale review that
could have implications and indeed the
new local plan
potentially could have implications
further down the track
for uh local neighborhood development
plans and parish plans
um but uh the the the objective is to
ensure that we don't create unnecessary
work for our parish council colleagues
i'm sure we all welcome uh not creating
additional work but it's not needed
council of pemberton
councillor junior thank you
um just on a couple of questions if i
might
uh you might want to refer this to um mr
john perford um on the social affordable
housing
um you you mentioned the the amount that
has been built
but are we actually meeting need rather
than
uh just putting a percentage in are is
that is the need
substantiated and sufficient are we
being sufficiently robust on that
that one again on town centers
again are we sufficiently protected
against the recent changes
in uh permitted development rights um in
town centers and second finally
on the climate change the spd work has
covered quite rightly
and the interim until we can get the new
local plan
up and running uh but we there's there
was a lot of confusion
in planning around energy efficiency and
renewables
i'm not sure whether we are sufficiently
robust
in uh unable to address the energy
efficiency and renewable energy
requirements
until such time as we get a replacement
local plan
um are we are we happy that um the
that um we are going to be uh
covered for those until we can get a
local plan in place
i think before mr carefort comes in um i
want to state
categorically that uh whilst i note
the the observations from councillor
junior none of those observations in any
way shape or form
would go to the heart of the assessment
or in any way shape or form call into
question the sadness of the current
core strategy or it going forward
i'm quite happy i think i think it would
be useful if mr carefort
is able to briefly answer if not
um i would ask that mr kevin perhaps
with your forbearance counselor junaid
uh takes this offline and provides you
with we
with with sort of more detail around
that but i think just for the key point
to make it absolutely clear um nothing
of that
uh goes to the heart of the sadness of
the plan uh john have you got anything
briefly
that you can uh update or alternatively
as i say you can make arrangements to
update counsellor junior
offline on your return uh
yeah well i can
deputy leader you've touched we've
answered
the question actually um i think there
is a distinction between
is the is the local plan up to date or
is it silent on issues
and there there is a sort of nuance
there and i think on the on certainly
the two things that council junior
you raise and town says as a climate
change i think it's fair to say we're
the course race is more silent on on
those issues
rather than in not being up to date and
that's why as
uh council pemberton said the the south
workshop plan will really certainly
cover off the climate change issues
and we'll you know cover off on the on
the town centres and the the economic
issues
i'm not sure any any local plans have
really fully taken into account
the changes to permitted development so
certainly as as council pemberton said
uh it's not a case of the plan is not up
to date we are it's a robust plan
but we all accept and all acknowledge
that it could be stronger in certain
areas and uh climate change and
employment are two of those and that's
why
the southwesterly local plan is is
putting those two issues at the
forefront
in respect of affordable housing uh
you're absolutely right again uh
councillor junied uh
need is not simply about numbers uh
we've always made that point it's about
building the right type
of affordable homes um and i'm you know
i'm confident that we we are doing that
we we published an annual review
statement earlier this year
that confirmed that the spread of homes
we were building so
yes i don't know the details but i am
confident that we are meeting the needs
of our residents in in terms of the
affordability of homes thank you
yeah i would just add just one
additional point that the
the the question of pd rights and
commercial properties
converting commercial properties to
residential um i know that has been an
issue
that has uh in other parts of the
country caused some concern about the
the quality of uh conversions from
commercial to residential to date there
has been
no appetite expressed uh
for such commercial uh conversions in
this
district um i'm not entirely i don't
think we've got the right profile to
make it attractive in that sense um
so i think that that probably goes
somewhere hopefully to allay
the concerns that i share as well about
the quality of
commercial uh to residential under pd
rights
but if councillor junior wants any more
detail on those i'm sure on his return
john will be happy to pick that up with
you
would that be okay councillor junior yes
indeed particularly two of them i would
like to catch up
and have some more detail and i'll
undertake to to do that once
uh once um um john is uh careful he's
back at work again
thank you councillor thank you
councillor pemberton so the
recommendation
on page five is that the cabinet
formally endorses the findings of the
review assessment set out in appendix 1
and appendix 2
that the course strategy remains up to
date and continues to provide an
appropriate basis on which to plan
the stratford-unhaven district through
to 2031
can i have your agreement to the
recommendation please members of cabinet
agreed agreed
thank you uh so moving on then and once
again it's councillor pemberton
and we have the bishops itchington
neighborhood development plan
pre-submission consultation responses
pages 59 to 68. thank you chairman
um the bishop citington neighborhood
development plan is now
at its pre-submission consultations
phase
where as the local planning authority we
have
um put together a series of comments
uh which uh endorsement is sought as our
formal response to the pre-submission
uh document and that um
first of all i may i clearly before
councillor kettle
uh uh placed on record my thanks to the
bishop
parish council and their neighbourhood
plan development group
for the work that they have done and
working in conjunction with our officers
to bring
the plan to this stage so the
recommendation before members of cabinet
is that the schedule of significant
comments be endorsed and submitted
to bishop to paris council and then as
the formal response
to the pre-submission consultation
process associated with the draft bishop
signature neighborhood development plan
has set out in appendix 2. and secondly
that the significant comments set out in
appendix 1
in order to inform the parish council as
qualifying body
of the district council's formal reply
to the draft plan
be endorsed
do you have any comments well mr
chairman
um i think this is a i'm sure it's the
same for every community but i have
watched this document
um gradually emerge
um over really quite a long time i think
the parish council
uh looked for people to work on this
with the
staff to the very first neighborhood
development plans
some quite some time ago so this is a
great step forward for the village i
would like to thank
many people um who have worked
in the in bishop chichington in the
community
um i think we probably had three full
committees who've actually worked
through this document over the over the
last
seven or eight years so this is a great
step forward and i'd like to
congratulate all those who have made
such a lot of hard work
for this document um and to the officers
at stratford
for the support they have given uh i
said on john i'd be grateful
thank you councillor kettle i'm sure we
all wish to congratulate the people in
bishop citington who worked on this
and the recommendations on page 59 that
council of pemberton
outlined earlier can we agree those
members of cabinets great great
i need to abstain on that mr chairman
okay
thank you councillor cattle
so council of kettle abstains everyone
else is in favor
so moving on the pillarton prize parish
plan
april 2021 council of pemberton once
again
thank you chair um so this is a parish
plan
uh rather than a neighborhood
development plan
a slightly different process we're at
the point where
um the uh reported associated
significant comments um are ready uh
sorry i'm reading the wrong plate
wrong police there apologies i've just
dropped to the wrong page
apologies uh yeah we're at the the point
where
uh we are now in a position to adopt the
peloton prize parish plan and
for it to be used um as a document that
is a material consideration for planning
applications
and the recommendation isn't the
pillarton prize parish plan
and its action plan so that's appendix
one the plan and the action plan of
appendix ii with the exception of
guiding principal pp
six one be adopted as material
consideration
members if i will draw members to
page 71 where there is discussion around
under 3.11 and 3.12
around local need
officers are
happy that to ensure the plan is in
conformity with the core strategy
um that that it should be adopted with
the exception of pp6
one um and that is the recommendation
um happy to take any further questions
if needs be
thank you councillor pemberton i see no
one
indicating that there are any questions
or any points to raise
so can i have your agreement to the
recommendation on page 69 please members
of cabinet
agreement thank you members of cabinet
so that's
agreed moving on now to item seven the
site allocation plan
specific site proposal rule 4 the
unveil council of pemberton again
thank you thank you chair members will
be aware that
the site allocations plan has gone
through its public consultation process
and this particular site was a site
that drew by
by a significant margin more
comments than any other site and
therefore
it has been the focus of uh officers
attention in terms of reviewing and
analyzing
uh the responses and it was felt that
such was the public interest that
this should be brought forward in
advance of the remainder of the
site allocation plan review work
members i am going to propose an
amendment to the recommendation
um the recommendation under uh under
item one is that the
rural foresight of me unveiled the
former engineers resources depot
longmarston
is not progressed as a housing
development allocation
within the forthcoming proposed
submission version of the site
allocations plan
so that that recommendation is as your
per your papers um what i am proposing
and seeking
a a second for is an amendment
to the second recommendation and that
recommend
and that amendment will remove the words
some
or from recommendation two so the
recommendation two will
now read that that the entire rural
foresight
former engineers resources depot be
identified within a site-specific green
space policy
in the forthcoming pro mission proposed
submission version of the site
allocations plan
policy will be informed by detailed
assessments of the site in relation to
its
environmental and historic value
to give members some context to the
proposal for the
amendments um officers uh
absolutely have got the message uh and
that message is loud and clear that
uh it is the intention that this site
be a a green um asset
for the residents of myanmar and the
wider district
uh the landowner the developers and
mudwins have
actively sought to withdraw housing
development proposals
so everybody is on the same page about
the future of the site
officers originally were wanted some or
all really just to give them the largest
amount of flexibility
uh uh in terms of coming to the best
future solution in terms of
uh the future of me on veyo whilst that
is laudable and
professionally quite right i think it is
important that we send a message
that there is no ambiguity whatsoever
about the future of this site so it is
my view that
um any potential ambiguity created by
those words should be
removed i'm cognizant also that
um the overview and scrutiny committee
considered the matter
uh and and they themselves were reminded
that
uh the the recommendation look at the
entire site
um they have also made some
recommendations
about uh actively uh
exploring a specific local green space
designation for the site
in conjunction with offices i've
considered this further
recommendation to cabinet by overview
and scrutiny and whilst i absolutely
understand
the uh the desire behind behind
that in his office's uh firm
professional view
that um the the wording of the
second recommendation by um overview
scrutiny
actually uh starts to
narrow down options rather than to have
the best
possible and widest possible options uh
for
the the most appropriate uh development
of neon veil to
to become a green site a green lunger is
a phrase that's been used often by the
site
so on that basis members committee i'm
not minded to support
the uh recommendations by overview and
scrutiny
that the proposed submission version
that um has this site
uh with a formal local green space
designation
and there are there are there are a
number of different
moving parts to all of this and our
officers do need to be
and i have confidence in our officers to
have the flexibility to achieve
uh the right outcome so i'm i'm seeking
a seconder for my
um my proposal uh and of course then
i will take any questions council of
pemberton
councillor shenton has indicated he's
willing to second your proposal
can you just please confirm that uh
verbally councillor shenton
i am very happy to confirm um
the amendment to recommendation too yes
thank you i now have a number of people
who wish to speak
starting with uh councillor o'donnell
thank you leader so i just wanted to
furnish
the cabinet with what was actually
proposed um and thank you council
pemberton for outlining what was
discussed at osc but i think it's
important that also cabinet
even though you've already proposed and
seconded um are furnished with what was
actually suggested in our recommendation
and we considered the report very
carefully after receiving
representations from both the ward
councillor and the chair of residents
association
and following input from the cabinet
member and policy manager unanimous
support for osc's amended wording
was that osu was asking to protect the
entire site as part of a site-specific
green space policy in the forthcoming
proposed submission
and the version of the site allocations
plan and explore formal
local green space designation for the
site and what we'd actually asked in
addition to what council pembroke read
out
was that um as part of this officers
should actively explore
formal greens formal local green space
designation for the site with offices
given flexibility
to include any additional green space
should that become available so that was
the
extra wording we were asking for as i
say you have already proposed and
seconded therefore that is decided
but do you think it's important for
clarification around the arguments that
you are aware that that was what was
proposed
thank you thank you council o'donnell
councillor parry thank you leader
i just wanted to particularly express my
thanks
um to councillor pemberton for having
the foresight in the first place to
ensure
this particular development was
incorporated
in the site allocations plan i know it
was very controversial at the time
but in fact if it hadn't been included
in the site allocation plan
we wouldn't be in the situation where we
are now
to give local residents the confidence
that
the there would not be that it wouldn't
be developed
so i think i certainly would like to
place recognition
um to council pemberton for
for going down this route particularly
and also our thanks to the officers
and i'd also actually like to thank
members of the osc
for looking at the report in such a
diligent
way um and i think you know their
efforts
have been recognized and it is without
this scrutiny we wouldn't be where
we are today so particular thanks to
pennian o'donnell
and also to councillor junit and also to
councillor
um edward fitter who i know has had an
active role
in this respect thank you chairman
thank you councillor parry your points
are well made and are noted counselor
junior
yes and i know the ward member is is um
has indicated that she wants to speak so
i won't
i won't go over the her the issues that
she will raise
but just to um second uh councillor
o'donnell
that the ovum scrutiny committee made it
clear
that they wanted and sought the maximum
protection possible for the site
and that they wanted uh the ability and
flexibility for officers to extend the
space
if the opportunity arose and uh thank
you
uh councillor donna for making that
quite clear that that was the
view from the overview and scrutiny
panel as well
so i'll leave the rest to the board
member
thank you councillor peter geller
okay thank you very much thank you
leader for allowing me to speak
um so i i'm very pleased that the
recommendation
um is to remove the allocation for
housing
um in a rural for proposal and to
safeguard the site
in a green space policy in the
forecoming proposed submission version
of the site allocation plan
which is exactly what we asked in our
amendment a while back
i'm also grateful to the overview and
scrutiny committee for their support
to make a change to the original second
recommendation
which is that the entire site be
identified within a site
specific green space policy um and i'm
pleased the council of pemberton has
proposed
the overview scrutiny committee's
amendment
of removing some or from the second
recommendation
however uh what i would i would say that
we would have liked to see the policy
warding at this point
the exact policy warding uh and and
that's why we suggested local green
space because the local green space is a
specific designation policy
in the uh mppf um and so
that tells us what kind of the manual
development is permitted or not um
so what i would ask is that i would like
to see
as soon as it's ready the exact policy
wording
of this um green space uh
for for the site for rural four thank
you
thank you very much councillor pemberton
do you wish to respond to that
absolutely thank you and again just to
repeat for the avoidance of doubt
um every everybody's on the same page
about
the future for this site as i said right
at the top
um because of the public interest it was
felt that it was appropriate to
uh bring the response and the
high level outcome into the public
domain
and before both the overview and
scrutiny committee and cabinet at the
earliest possible opportunity
what what officers have not had the
opportunity to do is actually work up
the detail of what that policy is going
to look like how we're going to achieve
it and there will
have to be those discussions um and it
and that is also informs my view that at
this point
um a particular designation or otherwise
it is not the right is not the right way
to go having said that
to give the categorical reassurance that
the direction of travel is where we all
want it to be
um i i note that the county have views
around
uh wildlife site designations and other
things so
what i wouldn't want to do is is for the
law of unintended consequences to apply
and that we we inadvertently
uh don't achieve the absolute best
outcome um and i think
you know we can uh have confidence in
the officers that they
they have the steer from the public and
from
members of the council as to where this
goes
uh and i have no doubt whatsoever that
when that work is done and
there is a clarity about the policy
direction
that that will be brought and that would
be part of discussions with ward members
both yourself and councillor fitter
as part of that process and undoubtedly
the overview and scrutiny committee will
quite rightly want to look at the detail
of that in the future
so i'm quite comfortable about that
thank you thank you councillor pemberton
councillor cargill
thank you chair i thank to the council
parrying council pemberton have actually
said most of
what i was going to say but i feel that
this demonstrates the need
to adhere to the procedures so that a
robust defense can be made
to prevent inappropriate development
within our district
if we hadn't done that we wouldn't have
the evidence base and therefore we
wouldn't be able to
necessarily push that forward especially
say for example as an appeal
and also i've no doubt that the actions
of the council
moved some modern in the right direction
to withdraw this
from the uh psychiatrist plan so again
uh just saying well done to
all all concerned thank you councillor
cargill
and that was uh a timely reminder that
uh
due processing procedures do have to be
followed
uh so the recommendations on page 87
uh as amended proposed by councillor
pemberton
and seconded by councillor shenton which
deletes
some ore in uh recommendation
two members of cabinet are you happy
with the amended recommendations
thank you members of uh cabinet so we
now move on to proposed performance
management framework uh
councillor cargill thank you chad
um this obviously we've uh we had to go
through these procedures
to bring up the the performance
management of the of the
council um i would say straight away
that this will be changed
when we start moving more into the
merger
with the warp district council
inevitably
there are a number of good statements in
here
fine statement however i do feel perhaps
that we need more detail on how these
are going to be
actually implemented uh and how to do it
in a manner
to work with warwick district council as
well
uh again this is something i think we
need to actually
send some significant time on uh
determining that
uh and i'm looking forward to working
with the offices on that particular
point
otherwise members i'd just like to
recommend this to you
and i will take any questions if i can
possibly answer them
thank you councillor cargill uh
councillor harvey you wish to speak
uh thank you leader um could i refer
members of the cabinet to page 107
there is a reference there to reducing
the target for the percentage of
household waste to be sent for reuse etc
from 61 to 50.
um uh given the success
of the garden waste scheme um
does councillor cargill still think that
a reduced target of 50 is is appropriate
or would you like to suggest it or would
you like to consider that it might be
increased closer to its original of 61
i'm going to let uh council shanton
respond to that particular one
very wise counselor cargill councillor
shenton
neatly passed off um
you may well be right uh councillor
harvey that uh
50 is too low but when
we initially uh looked at the the
targets
we weren't sure what kind of response we
were going to get
um obviously to the subscription scheme
it it is certain that it it it will fall
back
probably in the short term certain
probably it's
probable it might fall back in the short
term
um but i think as as councillor cargill
has said we will
sort of review this and maybe this will
be one that we will amend
um over the coming weeks when we've got
a better idea
of uh of the the final subscription
numbers
and the target for nationally
um over the next couple years is 55
um so i i would probably
be thinking in terms of that fifty
percent was the target
for uh to this daughter last year
um and that was nationally so i think
review yes but it may be just a little
bit too soon it may be
at the first quarter or the first time
these numbers are reported
we amend at that point thank you
councillor shenton uh i now have
uh councillor junaid followed by
councillor barker followed by councillor
kettle councillor junaid
um can i erase uh one query on page 100
with it which is the cp2a
the gateway packet which has been
on the cards for an awful long time i
just wanted to know
um whether that strategy of september
2021
is uh is is going to happen and what the
process will be
of ever informing counselors about the
progress on that one
that's number one i also have a question
on page 110
which is about the percentage of
residents who feel that they can
influence decisions in their local area
and the proposed target there is 37
percent
which i really do feel is far too low
if we are to be as democrat
if we are to support democracy properly
thank you well obviously the uh the
second
item first i suppose to a certain extent
depends on historical data but i'm sure
dave buckland can help us on that one
plus the first point tony
perks would like to respond to that one
mr perks thank you just
just struggling to get unmuted for a
second their leader uh thank you
councillor cardin councillor junior
um yes we are currently still working
very hard to look at a solution for the
gateway project we have discussions
ongoing and i would hope that by
september we would certainly have
something significant to report one way
or the other so
i'm confident whilst we're going to plug
the project completed by then we'll be
in a musician's
report to cancel the progress on that
site
i think what i would just add the uh mr
perks and for
counseling units benefit uh
this is a very very complex project it
is not easy
there are an awful lot of stakeholders
uh but we are beginning to move forwards
on it
would like to comment on the percentage
of residents who feel they can influence
the uh decision to the local area
if i could respond
and then council council card was
absolutely right that the target there
reflects the the uh position that we
achieved in the previous resident survey
um so yes it is based upon historic
information it's not
undertaken every year it's that i'm
saying every other year
um i think there'll be another
opportunity to review that target before
we actually expose ourselves to
any further visited survey
thank you on that particular point chair
if i may just say that
i have challenged the executive to
review their um targets
and the senior managers as well so again
this is part of ongoing process
i have no doubt that you know these will
over time will change inevitably
but they are robust i believe as we
speak
thank you thank you councillor barker
sorry very slow to unmute as well
forgive me
um yes page 103 priority six
is the bit which i'm referring um
in terms of creating a working
environment
that's agile etcetera and the increased
digitalization
and i had some really happy news today
from
mr platts um that we opened the doors at
elizabeth house today
for four hours i think it was four hours
yes four hours
um 10 till two and we had 53 visitors
through the door
council tax planning elections green
waste parking and various it wasn't just
parking
um and there were there were people
asking questions about orbit
um so having our front of house open was
really really important
and also our vision visitor information
center did a really good job
um the first visitors this morning come
from london it was their first day out
in 10 months
and another family from london met their
daughter from yorkshire
and they pick stratford as the halfway
point
um to reunite having not seen each other
for nine months
now i share that with you because there
will come a point where we have an
argument about
uh digital working and uh actually
seeing real people in the real world
and i'm a big proponent of seeing people
in the real world
and i'm just putting a stake in the
ground on that one now by giving you
those numbers
thank you thank you councillor barker
not only that you've added some
interesting texture to what's actually
happened today
so thank you for that counselor kettle
no can i just respond to that
uh sorry like soco no problem uh
point noted this is a people
organization
not only do we employ people work with
people
we serve the people so yes
that is the priority however as with
any organization we must modernize
we are in that process now we've had the
ways of working
the transformation and it's been
successful
it really has but we we will have them
further to go
we will never be completely digital i i
mentioned
i think previously that there will
always be a need for people to be face
to face
but quite often and especially with a
modern generation
majority of them will be using their
mobile phones
for example to communicate and they
won't necessarily want to speak to
people
but as i mentioned there are pretty
people
with learning difficulties dementia all
those sort of things
those will have to be catered for and
absolutely essentially so
i don't know if david arkington would
like to make a
comment on that one before we move on to
council kettle
mr elkington
cargill has set you up nicely absolutely
um but all i can say on that is i know
that it's in um
in the document to review uh the
council's digital uh
policies and our digital strategy going
forward
just to offer some reassurance what
we're seeking to do is not
um create a situation where the only
method of connecting to the council is
through a digital means i mean counselor
cargill's right that has been
uh you know the last 12 months have seen
some really dramatic shifts
in how people actually do um communicate
and how they use technology but there
will still be
uh inevitably a need for some services
to remain face to face so what we're
actually looking to do with our digital
strategy
as we develop it is find a way of making
sure
that the services that people out access
they operate in the most efficient way
possible
that we exploit every digital technology
that we've got access to to make sure
that we can actually deliver first-rate
services
for the residents of stratford uh that
that's the goal it's not to
not to try and alienate people or stop
them using face-to-face services if
that's what they really want to do
because inevitably there will be people
that want to do that it's it's about
improving the services and making sure
that we we offer the best that we
possibly can using all of the technology
we have
thank you mr elkington can i just come
back
on that um i wouldn't like to sound like
a luddite because i'm not actually
but i'll just share with you a quick
story that mr platt shared with me this
week which i think is pertinent
which is grandson says to grandad why
don't you do your banking online
why don't you get your shopping
delivered online
and grandad goes out with grandson and
meets somebody at the butcher and
somebody at the baker
and at the bank and he says because you
know
look at the number of people i've seen
and the people i've spoken to
and that is where i communicate with
people
and that is where i see people and so
particularly
in terms of combating loneliness there's
nothing there's
there's actually quite a lot more to
this and uh i was just poking a little
bit of fun at
councillor cargill as he well knows
you councillor barker
now uh i've got chris kettle sorry
councillor kettle and council
shenton and then we'll draw this to a
close counselor kettle
ah thank you mr chairman um yes point um
uh my first point is on page 99 cp one
a um raise the district profile
nationally regionally to deliver
benefits
residents um as we know
uh we welcome significant numbers of
international visitors to stratford
and i just wonder why we have
not included international
um among where we're trying to raise our
profile
and i think from recollection
speaking shakespeare's england the
considerable part of their effort is
also spent overseas in raising the
profile of stratford
uh so this is question one um and
question
my second question is um
as you know bluetooth safety is part of
my portfolio
and i'm not quite sure how but under a
kpi
whilst we do have certain kpis related
to community safety
um there is quite a lot more data
that has been generated uh about how
people feel
in the district about how say they are
and as to whether we should include
uh a measure of how people feel about
community safety within the district
and to monitor that
thank you chancellor kettle uh
sorry councillor cargill uh can i just
pick up the point about international
tourists you're absolutely right and
sorry councillor cargill
i have used the opposition nothing the
slices i think you're just saying what i
was going to say
i don't know if uh television wants to
say anything on that particular point
but i would also reiterate that this is
the
uh relevant of the managers for example
departmental managers
will will put these things in but i
think you're absolutely right that
there's an omission that we should
should look at as well we are part of
shakespeare's england correct me if i'm
wrong
and so therefore we should have a
presence there as well
on the second point you mentioned about
data
and uh and community safety and social
media again practicing it can be raised
in the respective portfolio please
yeah yeah uh mr brooklyn do you want to
respond to these specific points
yes thank you chairman i mean it's clear
obviously we want
to be put absolutely back on the map as
an international tourism destination
i think though likely and where we are
concentrating in
at least this the immediacy is to try
and ensure that we get as much of the
domestic
tourism market as possible to support
the district so yes absolutely long term
see that as an ambition of shakespeare's
england to to regain that
that the visitors that we we used to
enjoy um
from our international uh visitors but
in the short term
actually looking at the domestic market
thank you
thank you mr brookland uh
can i now move on to um
councillor shenton and then i've got
councillor jennings and then we really
do
pull it to a close thank you chair
just uh to make a change um i'd like to
just talk rubbish for a second
um as
counselor harvey brought it up i just uh
wanted to check the
the targets and i mentioned the 55
percent target
that's a tar european target by 2025
so and the other european target is that
landfill should be less than 10
by 2035 well on that score
we're already at seven percent um so
we're well ahead there
we will achieve the the uh 2025 target
of 55
well before this so i'm quite
comfortable with that over the last year
uh if you see look at the target in the
in on page 107
it says the target we should aim for
greater than 61
and we're achieving currently
percent uh according to the county
um so there is that that's a good result
of notwithstanding the fact that we will
see as i say a fallback
and if the the only other quick comment
i'd like to make is that
i think the the all these targets um and
objectives
uh underline a big commitment
uh going forward and uh show that we're
not willing
to just rest on our laurels and that we
want to drive the the district forward
and take advantage of national and local
funding as well so i think these
recommendations
are well worth supporting the
recommendation is
worth supporting thank you thank you and
just finally
before until uh just say that
counter-shanton is a really rubbish
friend
thank you counselor cargill
councillor jennings please restore some
sanity
ish yeah thank you chairman yeah it was
just about the uh
the tourism offices that comes under my
portfolio i mean
although a lot of the surveys have all
been saying we're not going to get
international tourists back
till 2024 2025 possibly
i think the third wave going on in
europe
is is very much an example of that
um but an oxford university just
recently did a
survey as well and they don't think it's
going to be back till
2027 but obviously we don't know what
the future holds but
so but what we do know is for the next
few years or so
it's domestic tourists who are going to
be coming here not
not international ones unfortunately
thank you councillor jennings uh can i
just say
that i think that has been a really
useful debate
i think the fact that we are questioning
and not just accepting
is really good obviously as councillor
cargill has stated time and time again
these will be kept under review but i
think it is interesting that members
have participated in a good debate
and actually looked very carefully at
the proposed performance management
framework nevertheless
what we have in front of us is a stake
in the ground as we are now
so the recommendations on page 95 there
are three recommendations there
can i have your approval of these
recommendations please members of
cabinet
thank you members of cabinet so
uh that is agreed so moving on
uh a unblock items are the cabinet work
program
climate change panels markets forum
and as no one has
indicated they wish to speak on these
um
sorry counselor junior the request
should have been made at the start of
the meeting
it was just a matter of correction
actually uh because i was i didn't work
for warwickshire county council i worked
for warwick district council
and the minutes need to be adjusted
accordingly thank you council agent will
make sure that happens
uh councillor kettle
you have not indicated that you wish to
speak on any of these at the beginning
of the meeting
sorry mr chairman if there's something
which um it might be of interest to you
um is the climate change change panel
um interested in
the costs of the extent extensive
additional works
of hs2 as to how much the additional
working of the
12 months might add i think
this is something that should be taken
up with the climate change panel not
with cabinet
but it probably will be of interest
uh any urgent business i've been
notified of none
in that case i declare the meeting
closed at 4 24.
thank you everyone for your attendance